hey there I'm turning to Coco and we're
in the CBS this morning
Toyota green room with recycle across
America founder Mitch headland that's
there right there
her organization aims to remove all
doubt and confusion and there's a lot of
it all doubt and confusion about the
recycling process how by standardizing
labels on recycling bins
good morning Mitch it's morning I think
before we get into some tips on
recycling we should make a few points
first one being that recycling is not
dead and it matters it does yeah so
recycling I think a lot of people are
hearing that it's dead and that
everything is going to the landfill and
going to the incinerator and what's the
point and I think it's really important
to say it's not completely dead I see
you as you put it it's an ICU and
sometimes you know things have to break
a lot before everybody takes notice and
really steps in to fix it so to believe
in I mean believe it or not at this
point even when recycling is at its
worst I had the most hope for it that
I've ever had which would make it right
now your hope level is through the roof
in part because recycling at the moment
isn't is in some trouble
one of the big reasons why recycling is
in trouble is because people don't know
what to recycle and they stand there in
front of the recycling bin and they do
something called wish cycling where they
hold say paper towel and they're not
really sure if a paper towel can be
recycled but they hope it can be so they
put it in the bin it's aspirational
recycling and that's a big problem
because when when recycling is
contaminated there's no market to resell
it and there's no market to resell it
the recycling companies end up taking to
the landfill so let's go through some of
the tips and they are voluminous there
are nine of them hear from you on how
people can improve their recycling
success so no plastic bags ever and
recycling bins no plastic bags no
plastic bags can I say that again a
stick bags don't even buy them if you
can avoid buying them in New York you
just passed a statewide with California
ban on plastic bags but we we don't need
them as much as we think we do so avoid
them but also when it comes to recycling
not put them in your recycling bin and
do not put your recyclables in the
plastic bag and then put it in the bin
plastic bags are a complete nono for a
recycling bin entirely so if you're
walking around your house picking up
recycling and you're doing it in a
plastic bag you're creating problems
well I mean if you do happen you have a
plastic bag and that's the way you're
collecting it then go to the recycling
bin empty it out and then either take
that plastic bag to a grocery store that
might have a recycling program or if you
can't find that then throw it in the
trash or reuse it somehow but avoid it
in the first place but definitely don't
let it go into the recycling but what
happens if you're making yourself a
sandwich and you find you're at the
bottom of the peanut butter container
you hear it clinking and clanking or
maybe it's a plastic container can you
recycle a food container like that or
may oh yes you can
so a lot of people say do I have to
thoroughly wash it do I need to put soap
and rinse and make it you know peanut
butter free you don't you just have to
make sure that you've scraped it as best
as you can and then put it in the
recycling bin the rest of the system
will take care of that but don't put in
a full managed or half maintenance jar
or you know of peanut butter jar that
has quite a bit in there just scrape it
out but you don't need to wash it don't
have to wash it okay now
plastic containers is a little bit
tricky you think anything made of
plastic is probably recyclable but what
are the rules on containers first off
don't trust a chasing arrow the little
recycling symbol yes do not chase that
or do not trust that chasing arrow
because it's clipart it's not protected
there's no oversight so it gets put on
anything including styrofoam which often
is not recyclable another thing
everybody should avoid so right now I
would stick with number ones and number
two so if you see a plastic with a
number one at the bottom or a number two
at the bottom then recycle that but to
be honest with you even that gets
confusing so I make it even simpler only
bottles plastic bottles anything with
the neck whether it's a shampoo bottle
or a soda bottle or a milk
recycle all of that and anything that
doesn't have a knack right now if you're
not aware of what you can recycle
whether it's a yogurt cup don't be
afraid to just let it go into the trash
right now but it doesn't feel so bad to
do that it does but if if you're not
sure about those then always stick with
a bottle with a neck okay that's kind of
a good good baseline and when in doubt
throw it out we're gonna get more on
when in doubt throw it out but what to
do with the caps for the bottles with
plastic they actually want the caps on
okay so if you have a cap don't just
throw it in the bin but put it back on
the plastic container so the plastic cap
sometimes is a different material than
the bottle itself and in processing it
gets shredded and separated and the cap
is actually a good plastic supposedly
quality that they need so they want them
back alright continuing in the hot seat
Mitch what about wood paper not all
papers recyclable what are the lines
well stick with office paper that's good
quality it doesn't have a pizza wrapped
in it so clean office paper newspaper
and when it comes to things that are
like paper towels or tissues or napkins
those are never recyclable no tissues no
paper towels what about paper plates no
no paper plates I know it hurts avoid
anything that has been too exposed to
food and paper tissue is just not
something that's recycle so if at the
end of the day you're having a glass of
wine and celebrating your wonderful
green afternoon of recycling and you
should break one of those glasses of
wine can you recycle a glass like that
no and you can't and unfortunately the
industry is not telling these secrets to
people so people are doing their best
thinking okay it's those glass is
recyclable clearly I can put my my wine
glass in there along with my pickle jar
and maybe my orange juice glass that
broke or maybe a wind
Payne but those are not recyclable when
you can if you can still recycle glass
in a lot of communities this in right
now in the u.s. a lot of communities are
discontinuing glass for this very reason
but if you less like the original I know
Michael breaks your hurt and it's it's
fully recyclable over and over and over
and over again if it's done well but the
problem is is no one has told the public
don't put your dishware in there don't
put your glassware in there don't put
your windowpane in there and so when
those items get mixed in with the glass
and they're all broken those glasses are
different and they can actually
contaminate and break the other good
glass that they need for new jars and
you know before we get into some of the
analysis the the single-use plastic so
plastic lids plastic straws plastic bags
we thought we talked about none of that
is recyclable no no and refuse it don't
use it and if it is recyclable if you're
if you feel compelled to you know have a
plastic bottle with water in it versus
having your own reusable recycle that
but as far as everything else that
single-use avoid it don't buy it don't
use it go to a restaurant and a lot of
restaurants coastal restaurants
especially are starting to make the
decision whether their states will ban
it or not a lot of restaurants and
retailers are making a decision not to
offer plastic bags anymore not to offer
plastic straws not to offer styrofoam
cups anymore and you know a pitch for
businesses that are doing that I hope
that all consumers that care about sea
life and wildlife in our life make a
decision to frequent those businesses
that are making the hard decision to get
away from single-use plastic it's
critical that we get away from it it's
it's detrimental given we're a big
country we've got lots of space we could
build lots of landfills we could throw
everything out for a long time a long
long time yes right so why bother
recycling yeah and great question
because people get really hung up on the
whole landfill conversation and
preventing the landfill is just a nano
fraction of the
AFET of recycling I like to point this
out now it makes me feel incredibly old
which I don't need any more of that but
when I was born there were 3.2 billion
people on this planet and now there's
seven point seven billion people on this
planet so the idea that we're just going
to keep using one time over and over
again and depleting all the resources is
insane it's it's a catastrophic math
equation
we can't go like we are right now where
it's just use and throw away we have to
get back into the system as a living
breathing entity of this planet which
all lives in a system we have to stop
thinking we're so smart to just have
everything disposable we're not
it's self-destructive the throwaway
societies yeah fourth China decided it
didn't want any of our throwaway is not
like it used to anyway are they the
reason we're having this recycling
crisis no and it's funny because I read
media every day about this issue and a
lot of the media is saying well
recycling just doesn't want our
recycling anymore or China doesn't want
our recycling anymore and international
markets have changed and and that's just
not true I mean they it's the half truth
they have been warning us for over a
decade that our recycling is so
contaminated that we need to clean it up
or they're going to start restricting
how much they buy they warned us in 2012
of that that was called the China
National Defense green fence policy and
the US didn't clean up their recycling
and so now fast forward to January 2018
and they said enough is enough they're
buying it by the cargo-ship full and
what they get when they when it comes to
China and they unveil it is dirty
diapers half-eaten hot dogs you know
bowling balls lawn chairs
I love the bowling ball yeah yeah right
and it's it's not that people don't like
recycling they love the idea of
recycling but it's presented in such a
dysfunctional way that it's really hard
for the public to actually take it
serious and then on that point
number one when in doubt throw it out
but then number two we should have
standardized labels yeah it's a
no-brainer
it's just a no-brainer like we have
standardized road signs state to state
if people want to get involved with this
issue and talk to their policy leaders
or elected officials about standardized
labels what do they do well so we
started our nonprofit organization
recycle across America started a
society-wide standardized labeling
system so even if the rules are
different from one community to the next
we have a standardized label that works
for every one of those different
recycling rules and we are asking
everyone to text fix it f IX IT to four
oh six for nine to ask their elected
officials to start implementing the
society-wide standardized labels on
recycling bins so that the public can
start to recycle right and if they don't
listen when in doubt throw them out yes
yes Mitch headland from recycle across
America thank you very much thanks to
appreciate you and again you can find
out more about recycle across America's
let's fix it campaign at recycle across
America org